With nearly $4 billion in worldwide grosses
and counting, the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is clearly doing something right, but it's
still always tempting to imagine what might
have been if directors had chosen to do things
a little differently. Let's do a heroic double
take with these Marvel movie alternate endings
you might not know about.
BLADE (1998)
The version of Blade that made it to theaters
ends with our hero slaying a bunch of vampire
minions before settling in for a long-awaited
battle versus the movie's big bad guy, Deacon
Frost. Blade vanquishes Frost once and for
all with an overdose of anti-vampire poison,
which he delivers by kicking a syringe right
into Frost's forehead...making him blow up.
Kinda cheesy, but it works. Unlike the unused
alternate ending, which would have shown Frost
achieving his goal of becoming the Blood God
and morphing into a whirling fountain of blood...that
still somehow has Frost's face in it. The
sequence would be pretty dumb even with today's
effects technology—so you can imagine how
bad it would've looked with the digital effects
available during the '90s. Thankfully, we
were spared in the final cut.
IRON MAN 2 (2010)
The Iron Man sequel gave Tony Stark a pair
of bad guys to contend with: mad scientist
Ivan Vanko and Justin Hammer, a business rival
who partners with Vanko to steal the Iron
Man technology. Unfortunately for Hammer,
Vanko, AKA the villainous Whiplash, has a
few screws loose, and he isn't above double-crossing
his partner to achieve his ultimate goal of
revenge against Tony. Vanko ultimately ends
up dead and Hammer goes to jail, but in the
alternate ending, Vanko meets his maker a
little differently: blasted to bits at the
last minute after kidnapping Pepper Potts.
THE WOLVERINE (2013)
The Wolverine from 2013 marked Hugh Jackman's
sixth outing as the iconic Marvel mutant,
but none of them gave him an opportunity to
wear his classic comic book costumes. Director
James Mangold looked to fix this problem in
his movie, though it still hit the cutting
room floor in the end. In the theatrical cut,
the film closes with Wolverine boarding a
jet and heading back to rejoin the X-Men.
But Mangold's unused ending also includes
a glimpse of his bodyguard Yukio presenting
him with a box containing his iconic blue-and-yellow
outfit from the comics. You should've worn
it in Days of Future Past, bub.
ANT-MAN (2015)
Observant viewers may have noticed that Ant-Man
left a big loose end untied. After trying
to purchase Yellowjacket's size-altering technology,
HYDRA agent Mitchell Carson ultimately ends
up getting away with the tech during the movie's
final battle. Originally, director Peyton
Reed meant to finish his film by having Ant-Man
face off against Carson. But the crossover
demands of the Marvel Cinematic Universe dictated
a teaser prelude for Captain America: Civil
War, so that's a battle that will have to
wait for another day—perhaps during the
sequel.
IRON MAN 3 (2013)
In the original ending, Iron Man's foe the
Mandarin—actually an actor named Trevor
Slattery hired to distract our hero—is hauled
off to prison for his part in aiding Aldrich
Killian's evil schemes. That's a far kinder
fate than the one he suffers in an earlier
version of the script, in which Slattery uses
the unstable Extremis super-soldier serum.
And like many of the other poor schmucks who
used it, he goes out with a bang.
X-MEN ORIGINS: WOLVERINE (2009)
For many Marvel fans, one of the most disappointing
parts of X-Men Origins: Wolverine was what
the movie did with Deadpool. In Origins, the
"merc with a mouth" is reduced to a pale,
mute shadow of his comic book self. Director
Gavin Hood threw the character's fans a bone
with one of several post-credits scenes attached
to different prints of the movie. One sequence
shows a hand emerging from rubble and reaching
out to touch Deadpool's severed head, after
which his eyes open and he "shushes" at the
camera. Maybe he was trying to tell the audience
not to ask for refunds.
THE AMAZING SPIDER-MAN 2 (2014)
Comics readers know that Spider-Man has been
through a lot of changes over the years, some
more bizarre than others. He's always been
an orphan, with the death of his parents partially
driving him to play the hero after he was
bit by a radioactive spider. But in a deleted
ending to 2014's The Amazing Spider-Man 2,
Peter's father Richard reveals himself to
be very much alive. He even offers a variation
on Spider-Man's iconic motto, "with great
power comes great responsibility."
X-MEN: THE LAST STAND (2006)
Widely regarded as the worst entry in the
X-Men series, 2006's The Last Stand made a
number of unpopular decisions—like killing
off a bunch of beloved characters—that took
a soft franchise reboot to untangle. Even
though a series of alternate endings were
filmed for Last Stand, none of them would've
made the movie much better. So it's easy to
understand why glimpses of Beast returning
to help run Xavier's school, Rogue returning
to the academy with her powers returned, and
Wolverine going back to Canada, all ended
up on the cutting room floor. We still need
Professor X to mind-wipe our memories of the
Juggernaut.
AVENGERS: AGE OF ULTRON (2015)
With the biggest cast in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, the Avengers franchise has more
options than most when it comes to alternate
endings. Director Joss Whedon took full advantage
of this with 2015's Age of Ultron.
He briefly entertained the notion of working
Spider-Man into the story, an option nixed
by the studio, who still didn't have the rights
to the character during filmmaking. Whedon
also considered showing audiences a glimpse
of Captain Marvel in the final scene, another
idea Marvel Studios denied, since the character
hadn't yet been cast for her own standalone
feature. Finally, the director thought about
revealing that the slain Quicksilver was alive
after seemingly being gunned down during the
movie's climactic fight. However, Whedon correctly
realized that this would have cheapened the
character's death earlier in the movie. Still...we
wish we could've seen all the Avengers assemble.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one you
just saw.